[Music]
tom the floor is yours
hi everyone i am tom holland you might
recognize me as your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and i am here to
tell you that spidey's back for an
all-new adventure in spider-man no way
home i know people say this a lot but i
mean it when i say that you're gonna see
things in this movie that you've never
ever seen before i'm talking about
pumpkin bombs
sandstorm
the multiverse which okay you might have
seen them before but i promise
not like this and not together also
peter parker is finally heading off to
college and the word is out so yeah
everyone knows that he is spider-man
so throw your fan theories out the
window they're probably not true or are
they
and get ready to see one of the most
ambitious films we've ever made an
incredible story with lots of heart
laughter high flying action mind-blowing
effects and some insane villains no way
home is the culmination of the
homecoming trilogy and the start of a
multiverse of possibilities tickets on
sale now
tickets on sale now
tickets on sale now
dude
exclusively movie theaters
[Music]
you